NOW BACK TO "THE INGRAHAM
ANGLE."
THEY'RE CALLING HIM A RESPECTFU
LOOKING ONLINE.
THIS COMES FROM AUTOGRAPHS THAT
SURFACED ONLINE SHOWING KIANA
REEVES IN PHOTOS WITH WOMEN.
THE 54 -YEAR-OLD ACTOR HAS HIS
HANDS OPEN.
HE'S NOT HUGGING OR MAKING
CONTACT WITH THE BACK OF THESE
LADIES.
HE IS BEING LAUDED FOR HIS
RESPONSE FOR PERSONAL SPACE AND
BODILY AT PTOLEMY.
THIS MAKES ME THINK HE LOOKS
MORE LIKE AT THIS POINT.
I HAVE A FRIEND HAS A HUGE STAR
EVERY PICTURE HE TAKES IS LIKE
THIS.
HE SMILES AND CROSSES HIS ARMS.
HE DOES THAT SO THEY CAN'T COME
BACK LATER AND SAY HE GRABBED ME
.
IT IS ODD.
>> BIDEN OFTEN ISN'T TOUCHING
WHERE HE SMELLS THE HAIR.
TO GIVE THERE IS A NEW STUDY
HAVE TO TELL YOU ABOUT THAT WE
COULD ALL LEARN A GREAT DEAL
FROM.
PEOPLE ARE VERY TERRITORIAL
ABOUT THE SIDE OF THE BED THEY
SLEEP ON.
>> BE GRATEFUL I AM STILL IN TH
ROOM.
>> IN A STUDY CONDUCTED BY A
GROUP CALLED THEY'VE FOUND A FE
SLEEP ON THE LEFT SIDE OF THE
BED YOU ARE MORE IMAGINATIVE AN
CREATIVE AND IF YOU SLEEP ON TH
RIGHT, YOU ARE MORE ANALYTICAL
AND LOGICAL.
WHERE DO YOU SLEEP QUESTION MIKE
.
>> I AM ON THE RIGHT.
>> AT SEA, IS THIS PILLOW RIGHT
OR FOOT OF THE BED RIGHT?
I CAN'T FIGURE THAT OUT.
>> AZURE IN THE BED TO BEAR IT.
>> I SLEEP ON THE LEFT THEN,
BUT, DOES THAT MEAN I'M MORE
CREATIVE AND ANALYTICAL?
>> I READ SOMEWHERE IT ALSO
MEANS YOUR POLITICS YOUR THAT
MEANS YOU'RE A LIBERAL.
AND I'M ON THE RIGHT.
>> I'M THE MODERATION PARADE 40
PERCENT OF PEOPLE SAY THEY
SELECT THE SIDE OF THE BED
EASIEST FOR THEM TO GET IN AND
OUT OF VERY AT HOTELS ALL SLEEP
ON THE OTHER SIDE I THINK I
CHOOSE IT BECAUSE OF BATHROOM
PROXIMITY.
THAT'S WHAT I INSTINCTIVELY, I
THINK WE HAVE THE ADVERTISERS
COVERED.
>> DO YOU SLEEP WITH YOUR TV ON?
THAT'S MY QUESTION.
>> I DON'T WATCH TV.
>> ACCORDING TO THE MEDICAL
SLEEPING WITH THE TV OR LIGHT O
IS ASSOCIATED WITH WEIGHT GAIN
IN WOMEN.
UP TO 11 POUNDS IN TEN YEARS.
>> WHAT ABOUT LIGHTS EVERYWHERE.
I HAVE A TVA NEVER TURN IT ON
BIRTH.
>> WE GO AROUND THE ROOM BECAUS
YOU HAVE THE LIGHT ON YOUR.
WE HAVE LITTLE COVERINGS WE PUT
OVER THEM WHEN WE GO TO BED.
>> THIS IS RAYMOND IN NORMANDY
BECAUSE RIEMAN HAD TO SLIP IN
THE CAR SO WE SLEPT IN THE CAR
WHICH OF COURSE WE HAD TO TELL
THE PRESIDENT WE SLEPT IN THE
CAR.
I LOOK OVER AND WE LOOK TO THE
GLASS AND RAMEN HAS RAYMOND HAS
ONE OF THOSE AIRPLANE MASKS ON
AND AS THE PORTABILITY DOORS AR
LOCKED HE CAN SLEEP THROUGH
ANYTHING.
>> THE 60 -YEAR-OLD MATERIAL
GIRL IS REINVENTING HERSELF.
AS PART OF THE RELEASE OF HER
NEW ALBUM, SHE'S WEARING AN EYE
PATCH AND HAS ASSUMED A NEW
IDENTITY WHICH SHE SHARED WITH
HARRY SMITH.
>> MADAME X.
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
SHE JESUS BY COMMITTEES A SECRE
AGENT.
SHE TRAVELS THE WORLD, SHE
CHANGES HER IDENTITY.
>> SHE HIS OUT OF HER MIND.
SHE HAS INSPIRED ME.
I AM THIS WEEKEND GOING TO BE
MISTER THIN.
HIM BLOCKING OUT ALL THE
FATTENING LIGHT RAYS I'M GOING
TO SLEEP LIKE THIS ALL FATHER'S
DAY AND I'M KEEPING MY HANDS
OPEN WIDE WHEN EVERY YEAR LADIE
ARE NEAR.
>> LIKE A PRAYER, WE WANT THAT
SEGMENT TWO AND.
>> BORDERLINE CRAZY.